yeah I'm Jessica Lord I'm an engineer
I'm based in New York I'm really excited
to be here I've never been here before
and I'm really excited to have the
opportunity to give this talk I'm not
going to talk about how electron works
or how to use it I'm gonna talk about
how it even came to be I guess and so
first I want to say what electron is
some of you may already know you've
either decided you love it or you hate
it and so for those of you who have not
decided if you love it or you hate it
electron is an open source library built
at github that combines node and chrome
into a single environment so that you
can use web technology like HTML CSS to
build desktop apps that will run on Mac
or Windows or Linux okay so when we
start this story we go all the way back
to 2015 so long ago but actually
electron which at this point was called
atom shell was about two years old at
this point so electron is like six years
old now an atom was even older atom
github github text editor was even older
so it's 2015 and I was working at github
and I had just moved on to the atom team
and I moved on to the atom team because
I wanted to write more JavaScript and I
moved on to that team to do more
JavaScript not because I had any idea
about desktop applications or what the
woes were of someone who had tried to
build a desktop application before I'd
never ever considered what's the desktop
application how are people making them
how do they usually make them and the
reality was that native desktop
applications typically meant if you
wanted them to work on every operating
system you might have to have three
separate teams building three separate
apps to work for all of your users and
that's a lot of resources so you
actually may not be supporting all of
the platforms you may be only supporting
one or two and that had been the reality
of building desktop applications Oh No
okay not great okay there we are all
right so I was on the atom team and I
was there cuz I was pumped because I was
going to write JavaScript more and the
more I on boarded to the team and
learned about how Adam worked I learned
about Adams shell and that it was
actually pretty special that Adam was a
desktop app that worked on three
operating systems and that it was
because of Adams shell that I could do
all of this and I thought that was
pretty special I think Adams great I
still use Adam but as a text editor and
there's other text editors and Adam
shell was doing something that nothing
else really did and I felt like it was
doing something that was potentially
really empowering and so I learned more
about how the team arrived there earlier
on in Adams days they had sort of done
some shopping for libraries because
there had been this vision for building
the desktop app Adam it's when there was
chromium embedded framework but this is
this is my Goldilocks illustration
chromium embedded framework wasn't too
heavy it was all of Chrome in wjs didn't
embed node in a way that was as seamless
as it could be and the developers on the
atom team at that time we're talking to
people on nwj s and they met Chang zc
Ben's on github and they really shared
this vision of this other more perfect
bowl of porridge which could be Adams
shell and so github contracted Chang and
he started building Adams show and get
in Chang eventually joined github
full-time and that was kind of the state
of things
Adams shell was a dependency of Adam
maintained by one person meaning it had
a bus factor of one so if anything
happened to Chang it would be really bad
and and it was just kind of hidden there
as a dependency of Adam there was no
plan for it and just one person taking
care of it and so there were already
people
in this space wanting to build desktop
apps with web technology and so slack
and Microsoft were looking at this and
so if you already were in the headspace
you were already searching for a
solution you and maybe already tried n
wjs to you at least knew enough to
question like oh how is Adam doing this
and then you could go into that Adam org
on github and ruffle through all of the
repositories and then you would find
Adam shell and you'd be like oh this is
how Adam is doing it but that was kind
of the only way to know what was
happening until Microsoft did that and
Microsoft built an editor called vs code
which is like an editor just like Adam
but so they were going to launch vs code
and we knew about that on the adam team
and we thought it would be pretty silly
for them to launch a new text editor and
say that it was built on adam's shell
there was no reason for it to reference
another text editor and because you
could build anything with adam shell it
just then at that point seemed really
silly for whatever people built with it
to be tied in name to Adam so vs code
was the impetus to name adam shell
electron which is a part of it wasn't a
lot of thinking behind it but but i
honestly was pumped I'm like see people
are using this like let's do some stuff
like electrons awesome and I thought
this was going to be the kicking off
point and so in our team meetings and
our mini summits
I was the person when they were like
okay what's on our roadmap and I was
like electron stuff electron stuff let's
do something electron like let's put
resources into electron we really need
to not ignore this and I was probably
annoying but I was told electrons not
important which is wrong that no one
will work on electron
so wrong and if I want to work on
electron I should use my weekends rude
[Applause]
very busy so the thing is I persisted hi
I researched the space the usage the
people that were working on electron and
using electron what was missing what we
really needed and so I started building
roadmaps and I just kept pushing and
eventually I got my 40 hours to spend on
electron
still on the atom team as a person on
the atom team but who could just work on
electron and so inside of the github org
what was to my benefit was that really
you only care about github com
everything else is kind of outside the
scope a little bit like there's the
world of desktop apps there's the github
desktop app and there's atom and then
down trailing atom would be electron so
I got to be in this kind of special
position that I was a little bit out of
the way out of sight not too many people
bothered me so that's why I got to say
first things first documentation which
never happens and let's see if I can get
this to work without no I can't I'll
just keep going this way so I started
with documentation and I also started
with a static site because static sites
are great and maybe you only need a
static site and use your google jam
stack and learn more about how you
probably just need a static site I use
Jekyll because it was github and github
pages supports Jekyll out of the box and
so luckily Chang had written a bunch of
documentation already and I went through
all of that edited it made it consistent
language and then I made a standard for
the markdown semantics for it
and it was really important to me to
have a single source of truth the
electron Doc's lived in the electron
repo and everyone gets a copy if you
fork or clone or download electron you
get a copy of the docs it's really great
when the docs live in the source try and
do that and their markdown they're not
in some other language that requires an
ePub book thing software they're in
markdown they render on github people
have heard of markdown and so I made a
style guide that literally tells you
like how many how many h1 headers there
should be one on a page of documentation
and it goes on to say exactly how we
would describe what a method would be
and what an event would be and how to
represent these things and markdown and
it was important to have this be
consistent not only for the end users
but so that we could target it with CSS
later so we have a Jekyll site and we
have a folder of markdown Doc's on in
the repo so I never managed to learn
Ruby at github so I wrote a bunch of
note scripts inside of my Jekyll file to
stream out that Doc's folder oh yeah
sorry backing up every electron release
is a tarball
and because the code or the
documentation is inside the repo every
electron release contains that versions
Docs
so I wrote the note scripts to stream
out that doc folder and then basically
pops out the version number and things
like bread crumb information file name
information and all of this stuff so
that I could then generate the front
matter that Jekyll wants on the top of
its pages so that we would end up with a
site that would have really nice-looking
Doc's with information like the
breadcrumbs and the version and then
another part of making the standard for
how we were going to do documentation
was also saying
that all of the API Doc's are gonna have
a single line at the top that just tell
you in one sentence what this is so that
you don't land on a page with a sea of
text and you can just figure out our am
I even in the right place to begin with
and then part of working with electron
is that there are two processes main and
renderer and that's important and it's
different than other libraries and so
it's also at the top of the
documentation here so that you can know
that you're in the right place alright
so again making being really concerned
about how we were using markdown to
document the code was also knowing that
it was going to end up on this website
so that we could do things like target
elements like that some API is an
electron work only on Mac or they work
only on Windows and so knowing that it
was going to be on the site we can use
the CSS to make it a little bit better
and make these things look like tags but
it's also important when you're thinking
about that to not forsake the original
markdown don't do something so wild that
it then becomes unreadable and markdown
I wanted it to still be readable and
markdown but also something I could
target and improve with styles on the
website so that was the first thing and
then the next thing was how to get
people started on their very first
electron app I wanted people to get
started quickly I wanted people to be
able to understand and also I didn't
want to have a lot of extra work because
I was maintaining him doing all this
stuff on my own and then I had my next
kind of battle because I was still in
the atom team and still getting input
from people and Adam used to be in Ruby
actually before it was open sourced and
written in node and so a lot of people
on the team had come from that world and
they were like there needs to be an
electron in it like a rails in it and I
typed rails in it before and you get a
lot of folders and I didn't want that
experience for people coming into
electron I didn't want you
to run a command that generated a bunch
of folders that you didn't understand
and you maybe didn't need half of them
and the thing is there's nothing wrong
with an it scripts and scaffolding but
it was wrong for electron-electron apps
you could build a single app that it
runs in your menu bar and tells you the
weather and is this big and you can also
build slack so we could either build a
scaffolding system that prescribed one
way to write electron apps which there
isn't or we could build a scaffolding
system that supported every single
flavor and recipe of electron app
possible which is a lot of work so I
felt like we would just no we weren't
gonna do that
these are flags in an imaginary command
line scripts that just say no um luckily
I got my way and I got to do this
version instead which is the electron
Quick Start which is a bare-bones
electron app that you clone and then you
npm install and npm run and it launches
a very bare-bones electron app and so
for me i wanted it to be really simple i
want it to be a jumping-off point and
not do too much but also let people know
where they were so in this the dev tools
opens up so as a web developer you're
you can already orient to yourself it
looks like Chrome it looks like things
you're familiar with and then there's
only a couple of electron API calls just
to demonstrate what that is but other
than that it is super simple and when
you open it in your text editor you see
an index.html file and you know what to
do with that and you can start you can
start editing it and see the changes
right away so developers developers
developers
I prioritize the developers who did not
realize what electron was and what they
could build with electron I did not care
so much about the ones that were already
building vias code and slack because
they got it they were already in that
headspace they were already looking for
something like electron and I wanted the
people who didn't yet know that they
could do things with electron to know
and so the next thing I worked on was an
electron app that demos the electron API
so especially in the early days it was
still kind of confusing at what electron
was to begin with it was Chrome and it
was node and desktop apps and what do
people mean with native operating system
and it was I felt like one of the big
hurdles was still explaining to people
why you would use electron what you
would do with it and so the API demo app
is an electron app that opens up you
download it you already get the sense of
like Oh an electron app is something my
users would install like a normal app
with icons and it's a very familiar flow
and then you open it up and you have a
left sidebar of common electron things
like opening a new window printing a PDF
and some of these common native things
that you would use an electron and you
get to demo them and actually interact
with it and see like oh this is what
they mean when they say system dialog
and start to get ideas and see what you
can do with electron and a cool thing
about this app is that it's an electron
app and the sample code is the actual
code so we can use the node API to fs
read a file and then use the web api to
say the text content of this element is
what we just read from this file and so
in terms of maintaining the app when you
update the app the sample code is also
updated it's not two things you have to
take care of so reoccurring theme is not
giving yourself more work another thing
is that this was a few years
and es6 was still really new and I'm
targeting developed like web developers
who aren't using es6 everywhere and I
didn't want to write just because I
could I didn't want to write a bunch of
JavaScript that looks different to
people and but at the same time wanted
to highlight that a feature of electron
is that you get es6 out of the box and
so the API demos app explains that there
are three bits of es6 that we're using
and here's what they are it was constant
let each string templates that way
people are made aware educating them and
also just not writing a bunch of
different looking code because we can or
it's the new cool thing cuz it's not
about you also this app was built to
open up I wanted people to be able to
split it open look at the insides and
see how an electron app works and so all
of the files and folders are thought
about so that they all relate so that
you can open it up and you can find the
HTML view and the corresponding main and
process main and renderer process files
that go along with it and then there's
documentation about that folder
structure and diagramming of how this
app actually runs from start to
beginning which is something I would
love to see more often I want to know
like what happens when you run this what
happens first okay so I said that I was
prioritizing new developers that didn't
already know what electron was but
doesn't mean I didn't care at all about
the people who are already contributing
electron really needed those people and
needed the electron community and create
a space for this userland
ecosystem to evolve because electron had
been built for atom it had the features
that atom needed it didn't have the
features that a slack or a chat app
needed and so it took it took those team
to contribute those features back to
electron and that was really essential
for making electron better and making it
have tons of features and api's that
atom would never come to on its own
because they were never things that Adam
was going to do and so there is a place
on the site where it's huge now you can
contribute your electron app and the
goal was to help people find each other
so people writing electron apps could
find other people writing electron apps
and hopefully some of them were open
source and people could learn from each
other and then there's userland which
has all the stuff that the users have
built which makes sense for people to do
like building a react specific Wow five
minutes okay
a react specific tool for starting
electron apps with react so then
eventually one more atom person came
over to electron we got head count to
hire one more person there were four of
us we got to God electron to its 1.0 we
moved it all out of the atom org
it got its own org we had our own
meetings and it was really real and then
like Mary Poppins I went on my way for
greener pastures I wanted to work with
more women if I'm real so the electron
team is great now it's a lot different
but anyways that was my own thing so
final thoughts and why I thought any of
this was maybe worth talking about is
that community engineering is something
I when I look back at what I was working
on then and kind of what it would be
called now or what I was doing at all I
think of it as community engineering and
actually now I've seen ipfs do a job
posting for community engineer
ghin shiver at glitch is a community
engineer and and community engineering
is a thing and I think it's great and my
background in the urban design and
architecture I think is not so different
to why I found all of this work really
satisfying because it's about helping or
it's about how people understand and
experience a system and building tools
that put new developers first electrons
situation was also really different and
I think that worked to its advantage it
wasn't like Adam it wasn't Adam was
github vision and an internal vision
that had been shaped and cared about for
a really really long time and so
electron didn't have that electron
wasn't planned it was off kind of to the
side and all of that worked out really
great for electron and electron got to
be in this really unique position where
it was an open source project that
really responded to the community the
community is who had cared about because
there wasn't there wasn't this internal
github vision like there was for Adam
one day though electron will be gone and
it should be because it should be the
stepping stone to the next thing and if
you hate electron and CPU usage you
should hate more if nothing ever
replaces it because that's the problem
but it should be replaced and something
better should come along and I also hope
that our current ideas about
documentation and talking about code
will be gone too another thing I did
outside of like my official electron
capacity was challenging myself to try
to explain electron in the simplest
terms as I could and so I created the
site essential electron with the
limitations of each section has to be
two to three sentences it can't use
jargon if there's industry terms I can't
avoid they're defined below and there's
links on the bottom of each section for
more information and I just want to
- I love that people are doing more
illustrations and diagrams and I just
hope that keeps growing and we change
the way we talk about code and and who
we assume is reading our documentation
and so in general I hope that you see
ways to scale down and actually give
yourself less work so that you can focus
on people and yeah I guess that's it
[Applause]